we love you well thanks because you are
so proud to be Canadian you're always
giving back what does it mean to you to
receive the humanitarian or tonight
um you know it's uh obviously the
massive honor you know I sort of think
of like it as a another means to kind of
amplify the amazing people that I get to
work with
um you know it's part of what I'll
probably say up there when I accept the
award that you know it's it's uh it's
amazing for me to accept this it's
incredibly honoring but it's a truly is
a fraction of the the burden that the
folks who work at each of these
organizations that I'm lucky enough to
to work with uh that they carry each and
every day so you know um I have a
platform that can be spent you know kind
of like money and it's uh it's a it's a
nice place to spend it um with some of
these groups so I've been really lucky
to work with some pretty amazing people
who have expanded my own kind of uh
Outlook and mind in a lot of different
ways and uh and you know and I love uh
being able to give back to the country
that gave so much to me I was obsessed
with the show The Odyssey that you were
in way back in the day we're going way
back oh boy yeah that's okay we're
keeping it Canadian here with everything
that you've accomplished your career
your family wrexham I mean on and on and
on what would you tell that kid about
what your life is right now I wouldn't
tell them a thing because what was so
great about all that is that my
expectations have always been you know
almost at the floor yeah so everything's
been gravy since then and I think my
career in my life has been sort of
measured by a in an aggregate you know
it hasn't been I never had this
overnight success or anything like that
it's really allowed me I think to
immerse and give me time to kind of
acclimatize to everything slowly but
surely and probably one of the reasons I
haven't been you know completely chewed
up and spat out in this industry uh
early on it was just inch by inch the
hallway so I wouldn't tell that guy a
damn thing uh he could suck it and just
figure it out on his own all right I
like it uh we cannot wait for Deadpool 3
you and Hugh Jackman back together again
you posted recently a picture of you in
the gym with the caption keeping up uh
uh uh with the jackmans yeah how's it
going yeah I'm trying that Hugh Jackman
is a beast you know um yeah he's uh
clearly obsessed with his own body uh so
keeping up with someone who's who's that
diligent is going to be challenging but
um but yeah it's been it's been fun I
mean he and I are both really excited
we've wanted to do this for a decade so
to have this opportunity now is uh is I
think actually weirdly the perfect time
too did you tell him specifically
something to get him back on board
I mean I never stopped I was just
pestering I'm like a gnat uh over the
last many years I actually just think
it's I believe in timing yeah you know
it's as much as hard work and luck in
all those intersections that are
supposed to meet timing is a big one as
well and I think he was ready I think he
was uh um excited and what we pitched
him was enough of a Divergence from the
character that he knows and the
character that he's left behind that it
gives him something completely new to
play and something he's really excited
to do so so yeah very excited just to
wrap things up I'm the olds of five kids
so now try to have control issues but
I'm used to a big family love all the
chaos now that you're a dad of four yeah
how you handle on everything I haven't
met any of them yet but uh uh they seem
they seem great they have a private
Instagram account that I follow and uh
uh no I mean it's it's foreign
two to three was a huge jump or three to
four less so I think uh I cannot speak
for my wife uh but but I've sort of it's
just from what have I I've observed um
but we love it you know we would uh we'd
be idiots to do this again if we didn't
love it so oh and like we said you
wanted a big family yeah I come from
four Blake comes from five yeah um both
of us are the youngest oh how's that
working well I don't she's I'm the
youngest of four boys she's got a mix
there so I I know what it's like to uh
leave a home through the wall instead of
a perfectly good door she of course I
think had a little easier when she was
younger
so nice getting to talk to you you look
great such a big night for you so nice
getting to talk to you